CHET HAASE: Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer on
the Android team at Google.
I work on graphics and
animation, and today I wanted
to talk about drawable
animation.
Specifically, I want
to talk about the
transition in drawable.
This is a way to provide a
capability for you to cross
fade between representations
of graphics in your views.
So let's take a quick look
at the demo which I call
CrossFading.
It's a fascinating demo that's
going to cross fade between
two colored rectangles, exactly
the kind of activity
that you probably want
to write and
sell on the Play store.
So here we have a red rectangle,
and when I click on
it, we're going to see
a green rectangle.
And when we click on the green
one, we're going to see the
red one, and back and forth.
And if we click in the middle,
it'll stop the animation and
go in reverse.
So, not terribly interesting--
the code is slightly more
interesting.
Let's take a look at that now.
So we have this class
called CrossFading.
It's an activity.
It keeps track of the current
drawables so that it knows
which one to transition to.
And so we can go in here
and see how we do that.
First, we get the image view.
Then we create a couple
of bit maps.
We're going to create a red
bitmap and a green bitmap and
put them in the image view.
But instead of just installing
it as the drawable in the
image view, we're actually going
to create this different
kind of drawable called
a transition drawable.
And this one takes an array of
objects, these drawables
that's we've created, these
bit map drawables that now
hold the red and the
green bitmaps.
So we create the transition
drawable with those, and you
can think of this as being
layers in that drawable.
So it's a transition drawable
that's actually a set of
drawables consisting of two.
The red one is the first one
that we created, so that's
going to be in back, and the
green one is in front.
But the green one is not visible
by default, so it's
kind of an invisible layer
sitting on top of the first
one that you loaded there.
And then when we click, we're
going to fade between these.
So we go down here and
we listen for clicks
on the image views.
If the current drawable is 0,
which means we're now looking
at the red one, that first one
loaded, then we must need to
start the transition so
that we can see the
green one on top.
So we say start transition and
we give it a duration.
So this time it's going to run
for 500 milliseconds and then
it will fade in the green
one over the red.
So it's not really doing
a cross fade.
Instead, you see the red one,
and then we basically fade in
the green one on top of it.
And then we set the current
drawable so that we can track
that so that we know next time
we click which one are we
going to transition to.
If you want to go in reverse,
you don't start the transition
because start transition
always fades in the
one that's on top.
So if we did that every time,
you would always see the fade
into green, which is probably
not the kind of cross fade
effect that you're
looking for.
Instead, if we want to go into
reverse, we need to fade out
the one on top, and to do that
you call reverse transition.
So reverse transition will
basically fade out the one
that's on top, and then you
see the one, the first one
that was loaded, the one
that's on the bottom.
So we start transition, we fade
in the green, reverse
transition, we fade
out to red.
If we do it in the middle,
that's fine.
If we're in the middle of
start transition, we're
halfway there and then we click
on it, then we know that
we need to go back to red and
we call reverse transition.
It just stops and reverses
on the fly.
This is kind of a useful effect
if you want to do
something really simple
to cross fade between
representations of
two drawables.
It's not really good for a
general cross fading system.
If you have a picture viewer,
let's say, where you're going
between several different
images, there'd be a little
bit more tracking to say OK,
now these are my two
drawables, now these are
my two drawables.
There's probably a better way of
doing this, which we'll see
in a future episode, using a
more robust animation system.
But for doing really simple
cross fades between two bitmap
drawable representations, this
is a pretty easy class to use.
And that's it for today.
Thanks.